this week we're talking about functions
service meshes and more welcome to this
week and cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
first up flexible fun with functions
google cloud functions is focused on
simplicity and embracing serverless a
big part of that simplicity is being
able to choose your favorite languages
so we're excited to announce some
additional support now anyone can use
Python three point seven go one point
eleven and note eight
we're also working on node 10 which is
in beta and have private alphas that you
can sign up for for go one point twelve
and Java eight dive right in and get
your code in the cloud no matter the
language your services probably handle
traffic and you don't want to bake
networking policies directly into your
app code that's why everyone is talking
about utilizing service meshes and
Google clouds recently announced traffic
director
it's a managed traffic control plane
that helps support separating
development from operations through
service proxies such as envoy read the
deep dive and see if this helps simplify
your application one another best way to
keep a secret with encryption and with
Google Cloud Storage of course Seth
Fargo a google cloud developer advocate
has created an open-source tool and
library called Berglas that helps
simplify secret management it's also
built to easily integrate with cloud run
cloud functions cloud build kubernetes
or you can roll your own wrapper check
out the source code on github and get
started with some great examples now if
you're still learning about some of
those great google cloud options we've
got you covered with hands-on training
we've got a few new labs and quests to
check out from getting started with
cloud run to a full guide on modernizing
with google kubernetes engine there was
even a quest on getting set up with
google assistant so make sure to check
out the great content and try it out for
yourself on quick laps if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link of
course this week is Google i/o so stay
tuned for some great announcements have
any thought or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you